نتحول اذن الى صهيب العصا في كريفيري
ونريد ان نسال عن خيرسون ايضا صهيب يعني
الجانب الاوكراني حذر ومتخوف مما من هذا
الانسحاب الروسي الاول بدا باخلاء السكان
والان انسحاب القوات الروسيه والاداره
المؤلله لروسيا ما الذي يتخوفه الجانب
الاوكراني من هذا الاخلاء ولماذا لم
يدخلوا همم خيرس اذا كانت خاليه بهذا
الشكل
يتخوفون من من افخاخ او من فخ ينصبها
الجيش الروسي للجيش الاوكراني عمليه
الدخول الاوكرانيه الى رسوم تبدو بطيئه
ااه زين رغم الاعلانات الاوكرانيه عن تقدم
اليوم كان هناك اعلان عن استعاده اكثر من
150 كلم مربع من مساحات خير صور خلال
ساعات ال24 الماضيه يبقى اعلان رئيس
الاداره الاقليميه العسكريه في خير وهناك
ايضا بيانات عسكريه غير رسميه حتى هذه
اللحظه تشير الى تقدم نحو 17 كم داخل عمق
سيطره القوات الاوكرانيه لا يمكن القول
هناك من ناحيه الاخرانيه ان هناك انسحاب
كامل بمعنى اخلاء مدينه عمليه انسحاب صحيح
لا يثق وفقا تصريحاته بالتصريحات الروسيه
لانه صحيح ان هناك اعلان روسي عن انسحاب
هناك فيديوهات
يقولون انهم يتقدمون
رئيس الاوكراني بلودو ميرسينيسكي يوم امس
قال انه لا يمكن لاحد ان يغادر مكانا اذا
كان يشعر بالقوه في اشاره الى الضغط
الكبير الذي تشكله القوات الاوكرانيه على
القوات الروسيه في خرسون رئيس الاداره
الاقليميه العسكريه اليوم في خرسون يقول
ان العمليات العسكريه متواصله وان اي شيء
يحصل في خرسون فهو يحدث نتيجه الضغط
العمليات العسكريه للجيش الاوكراني في
خيرسون وبالتالي عندما نتحدث عن خير سونا
الان فا نحن نتحدث عن الروايه واحده هي
الروايه الروسيه الروايه الاوكرانيه تقول
ان العمليات مستمره ولكن لا تاكيد على
الانسحاب الروايه الاوكرانيه ايضا تشكك في
الروايه الروسيه بشان الانسحاب وتقول انه
لا يمكن الحديث عن استعاده السيطره على
المناطق التي تسيطر عليها قوه الروسيه الا
اذا تم رفع العلم الاوكراني في تلك
المناطق تقول القوات الاوكرانيه انا الان
ترفع العالم الاوكراني صحيح في بعض
المناطق في الجنوبيه همم جنوب الشرقي
وايضا نتحدث عن دخول 17 كم في عمق همم
ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه نت بعد المسافه ايضا
بعيده نتحدث عن حوالي 15 الى 20 كم بعيده
عن وسط مدينه خيرسون حيث تسيطر القوات
الروسيه حتى هذه اللحظه وفق الاعلان
الاوكراني
وهذا لا يمكن خلصن بحسب كثير من المراقبين
ستكون همم من اشد المعارك في همم المرحله
المقبله من همم كريفيري صهيب العسل شكرا
جزيلا لك